the federal government launching a new
tool to help you file for the new child
tax credit it's part of president
biden's american rescue plan
and gives american families hundreds of
dollars per child
per month now in order to qualify you
have to make 75 000
or less if you're single or a hundred
and fifty thousand or less if you're
married
families with a child under six will get
three hundred dollars a month
and families with children between the
ages of six and seventeen will get two
hundred and fifty dollars
that's for each child democratic
congressman stephen horsford tells us
more than 90 percent of families in his
district
are eligible i was listening
uh to one of the parents in my district
who has two young daughters you know
he's going to make sure that one
gets their their eyeglasses and the
other get to go see the dentist
that's how parents are gonna use this
money if you didn't file taxes this year
you can still claim the credit on the
irs's website
we do have a link to that for you on our
website at 8newsnow.com